[Applause]
let's go yes
and i want the part guy nicely colored
ronnie yes yes gordon let's go
greg taste everything and we're working
together aren't we what does it
look like it does it this saturday sees
the launch of the national vegan week
and in order to help celebrate we're
doing an amazing starter of lentils
cooked with carrots leeks and celeriac
finished with a slab of foie gras
[Music]
also on the menu tonight a fantastic
herb-crusted racquet lamp that you can
make
this weekend just 59 days to go
meet the f-word restaurant's christmas
dinner
[Applause]
and i filled the place with women to
launch my campaign to get women back in
the kitchen
amongst the diners is marty mccutchen
who can't even boil an egg
i don't have um saucepans or frying pans
i don't want one
and i've got paper plates because then i
can just chuck it
let's go let's go let's go quick now
fargo can be duck liver or goose liver
this is actually duck liver and it
actually looks like a sort of
block of butter we get it really nice
and crispy on the sides
and inside it should be served slightly
pink but you've got to be quick if you
leave in the pan too long
it disappears let's go
most people would never think of cooking
foie gras but it's so simple
don't leave it to the restaurant chefs
try it at home it's easier
than frying an egg good more salt in
there please
come on taste it first of all let me
show you
don't worry about starting with oil you
know that because fargo
is 90 what fat fat so why putting fat in
the pan
um stupidly stupidly which piece of them
would you put in first
um the biggest why because it takes
longer to cook good
second biggest third biggest
and smallest in right now we'll take it
off the heat
yeah there's enough heat in there to
still color it
till the pan helps cook the back of the
foie gras yes
back on the heat and turn it around
again
look at the difference in color now
through there now it's starting to break
down
i tilt the pan back up and then just
a little glaze over yeah
nicely and they should all come out
evenly yes turn them around again
carefully yes i'm serving the foie gras
on a bed of three lentils don't use red
lentils as they'll turn to mush
they're cooked together with what we
call a brinwas that's finely chopped
vegetables that have been sauteed
then i bind the whole thing together
with a fragrant herb vinaigrette
on the lentils let's go
are you happy with those yes wipe the
plates
go send it second time matthew table
five
foie gras excites a lot of passion
because some people think it's cruel but
i think it's delicious
and you should try everything at least
once i was a
foie gras virgin before i came here and
i really wanted to try it
so definitely definitely a good choice
it tastes like butter it tastes like the
most delicious velvety buttery
creamy deliciousness that just slivers
down your throat it's the most
fabulous taste in your mouth it's
slightly crispy but then inside it's all
just
like velvet stroking you inside your
mouth it's delicious
well i thought i thought the starter was
quite nice actually really lovely nice
and smooth
worked with the vegetables and it's
something i couldn't possibly cook
myself
really i heard the girl on the next
table say oh i'm not eating that
so we kind of had a word with our waiter
who negotiated that that plate came over
here as well
hello i'm good you're well yeah really
well thank you very much enjoy the
foreground yeah lovely evening
how many times a week would you eat out
normally well i eat out loads because i
can't
i can't cook to save my life i've
probably got a few crackers and some
crunching up context in the cupboard
mum must have thought you had to cook
somewhere along the line though um well
she tried but she kind of gave up with
me
and when i was about 22 she got me a wok
i said you can't go wrong you should
chuck everything in and cook it and then
i cooked fish with vegetables i didn't
cut
the fish properly and i was sick for
about 12 days and
since then i was so ill gold and i can't
do it again so prefer eating out rather
than cooking
good yeah especially someone like you
cooking for me how can i compete with
that
main course right lamb lovely blonde
potatoes courgettes problem sound
tomatoes herbs
light vinaigrette again um i'll be back
after that please eat it all
i will in fact the only thing i wanted
to leave yeah are the bones do you know
what you're the man of my dreams
the first one is help me to make sure i
eat it all right clean plate
i've never had that problem enjoy your
lamb pink medium well done
um for me well done no chance pink
oh no i've got to eat raw meat now
oh dear mr corin gordon another day
another meal yep another day another
meal guilty going out to eat for a
living i never feel guilty about
anything at all
and what's the wonder what it'd be like
to actually be a food critic sort of 365
days a year unimaginably good
so much better than being a chef i can't
tell you listen before christmas is
really important i would love to have
a food critic in the kitchen just to
show you an insight to what it's like
doing a full day's work and being up at
six o'clock in the morning that's like
saying unless i say to a policeman i'd
like to spend a day in prison i know
it's bad in there that's why i'm not in
there as a critic what do you think of
the startups
i've had better but then i have i have
so much it's a great piece of foie gras
yeah you know it's a
they're from they're from nice ducks
aren't they yeah they're hungarian yeah
but in terms of but in terms of the
provenance of it it's nice to know at
least
it came from uh i'm quite nutty about
that sort of thing there is a rumor
okay that you went into arrested once
and actually asked the name of the pig
before you let him
yes i have done that but really the name
of the farm will do and even though you
you laugh at me
you're more and more into this you've
got something going on at home which is
fairly sort of hugh fairly witting sauce
i mean i live in the city i want my
children to learn and understand
where their food comes from what's this
for
for the turkeys to live in that's right
and why have they got so much space
so they can run around run around and
get what
and exercise exercise exactly get a fan
get exercise surprise surprise
gordon's had one of his fantastic ideas
which i'm not exactly
over the moon about he's decided that we
are going to grow christmas lunch
he wants to make the children understand
that christmas lunch
you know actually comes from somewhere
not just from the supermarket so we're
going to fatten up the turkeys
and grow our own vegetables but meg i
think you get really attached to them
you know that
[Applause]
holly they'll be tough old birds
i want to hear the noise though no
louder
[Music]
lily pie go quick jump on come on quick
jump and again jump and again jump
they've got to be in this pen and we've
got to keep them away from the foxes
we've got a problem in this setting with
foxes because there's a lot of them
around those woods behind
what we're going to do is enclose
everything with wire
chicken wire and we're going to bury
that into the ground 18 inches
who's going to help me meet me
[Music]
my once perfect garden that i've spent
all summer having
landscape gardeners is now going to be
ruined
if you're naughty you're sleeping out
here with the turkeys as well
yes okay
you understand why we're here don't you
yeah yeah we're gonna choose
six of these birds to take home okay to
fatten up
for christmas are you hungry
would you like to eat one we have both
bronze and white turkeys they're all
free-range so there's very little
difference in it the bronzer just a
little bit gamer in flavour
and it's just personal preference really
chris need six turkeys for christmas
the idea of bringing them here today was
to sort of give them a sense of where
they come from
to make them understand that christmas
day isn't just coming out of a
supermarket
jack have you caught one yet come on
we've got four thousand turkeys here on
this farm yeah so how old are they
these are sixteen weeks old and they go
right up to 24.
these will be about 24 weeks whether
what's the difference in weight we'll
sell
the bronze turkeys from about seven or
eight pounds of them ready right up to
sort of
30 pounds okay three more
[Music]
turkeys need a diet which is rich in
cereals and so we put at least
70 wheat barley oats into the diet and
that gives us a lovely finish
and and that gives you a marvelous
christmas lunch
[Music]
tilly daddy's driving they're [ __ ]
themselves
hold on then welcome you home now we
have to think of some names for them
and i thought okay because there's six
of them okay we've got one each
okay we'll name them after chefs
okay yes yours is called gary
that's the one with a spiky bum gary
gary
[Music]
yours walks a bit funny so we'll call
him jamie
oh no look there is the stubble one down
the end the one who wants to be on
the lonely bird that's delia
what's yours called lily pie anthony
that's right the little dumpy one
like you
oh jack look after nigella
this is the real sort of happy chirpy
chappie
with a big neck we'll call him ainsley
lily lily why don't we take them through
and just show them
the oven very quickly
listen listen listen we got to roast
them soon
[Music]
look
right put him into bed now please come
on anthony move your ass
that's right you want a little kiss on
the breast all right
hi chris hi good how you doing i'm fine
love you man
good good good that's slightly different
from eating turkey however yeah but
there yeah i have got to just make sure
my turkeys are fine with you i can
guarantee that the
turkeys are in fine order getting very
plump and [ __ ] everywhere
just just just just put it down to
experience you know where there's money
any tips that you may have that i could
pick up on to sort of i suppose make
them feel a little bit more at home just
make sure they've got plenty of room yes
got plenty of food
water and you let them in and out each
day on time okay
right and maybe give them a bit more
grass when they've eaten off all the
grass and that little pen you got them
in
give them more grass it's worth it so
nigella's plump breasts are going to
taste a lot better than more grass than
my back garden she eats
alright so yeah
next on the menu rack of lamb and this
boat thinks his dessert
is better than mine but he has got more
hair than brains would you like to be a
proper chef one day
oh god no what put you off the house you
mate
i'm scared and i teach marty mccutchen
how to sharpen a knife
just like nine and a half weeks stay
good
[Applause]
welcome back to the f word the place
that you can find out everything you
need to know about food
next up is the main course season the
courgettes yes fresh puzzle in there
yeah i'll open up the seasoning let's go
main course tonight is the beautiful
rack of lamb served with the blunder
potato and
saute courgettes with tomato provencal
and i'd never ever thought ever say this
i promise however here's one i made
earlier
raka lamb this is the rolls royce the
lamb it is
every chef's dream to cook this
in kitchens especially in my kitchens
we'll always season them plates because
we don't want to waste any salt pepper
so once we've seasoned from a height
we then get the raka lamb and almost
sort of rub it in and let
the lamb absorb all that salt and pepper
so we're wasting nothing
[Music]
[Applause]
hot pan olive oil
it's simple mathematics no color no
flavor
get some color on there
skin side down hot oven seven to eight
minutes
herb crust
[Applause]
[Music]
i just picked some parsley parsley
rosemary thyme
that parsley gives a really nice dark
green color
great parmesan and seasoning
[Music]
and then just a drizzle of olive oil to
bring it together
blitz it
[Applause]
comes out amazing
[Applause]
[Music]
firm with the spring and it will be
cooked perfectly pink
dijon mustard whilst it's hot
the sort of mustard absorbs and melts
quickly into the fat and just makes it a
lot more flavoursome
and it's almost like sort of dipping
your lolly into sherbet
[Music]
crisp the breadcrumbs three to four
[Music]
minutes
onto the plate herb crusted rackoblam
done
right how long for the lamb
let's go i want it together yes five and
five yeah let's go
i'm joined by a hand-picked kitchen
brigade over there
is ronnie he's been with me now in three
years quite a delicate touch and a
bloody good cook
greg this guy used to be a management
consultant until he saw the
pilot light and he cooks as if he's been
in the kitchen 20 years he's only been
in
trade three years and every chef has a
right hand man and my right-hand man
is sarge he's been by my side now for
close to 10 years
the other two cooks in the kitchen who
look absolutely petrified
are our trainees we call them commies
matthew's a 20 year old waiter who's
desperate to make the step into the
kitchen
miller is 24 and works in corporate
hospitality
she's passionate about food but can she
handle being bossed about
move your ass neither of them has worked
in a professional kitchen before
with the lamb we're serving a boulogne
potato the most important thing about
this particular potato
is like a layered cake got these
wonderful caramelized onions potatoes
onions potatoes onions and then it's
cooked with a really nice stock so it
acts like a bit of a sauce
perfect for this time of year i'm
perfect with a lamb
lamb please bologna potatoes are easy to
cook but look sophisticated
and are absolutely delicious simply find
sliced potatoes and lay them in a dish
with sauteed onions
season between the layers and pour some
chicken stock over the top
into the oven for 15 minutes and that's
it like dope from wires
but if anything healthier and easier
let's go ronnie lemon four minutes on
the hot plate yep
let's serve with the lamb we've got the
sort of sauteed courgettes with tomato
like pop itself finish with a little bit
of buttermilk vinegar
courgettes are a very different
vegetable to cook because a lot of
people don't cook them enough
so therefore they get a little bit slimy
but so for them and olive oil
beautifully done with salt pepper
finish with a tablespoon of basmati
vinegar it's a really nice way of eating
them
just smell that now in front there smell
in there
yes okay how long for the first lamb to
an hour please gordon how long
no come on no yeah no i said i started
already i said both five and five come
on
let's go then yeah yes two and a half
right i want two pounds done at any one
time
oh god don't send anything yet yes
come on matthew how long on that lamb
never thought
so i'm here to help you and now you're
shouting at me how long the lamb yes
slice the lamb yup
do it yourself sorry chef let's go
miller
stupid pull the plates in towards you so
you can see them all the way around
shake the bottle miller shake the bottle
why are we shaking it miller um to make
sure it's emulsified so exactly so it's
evenly distributed come on let's go
right let's go come on yes come on
matthew
start sending start sending matthew
clean your place come on come on come on
come on
six on five miller yes matthew six on 15
yes
check what you're doing go i've got six
on 15 please
let's go so to follow mm-hmm rock-a-flam
boulangerie and courgette it's enormous
fantastic
let's go well with both hands matthew
speed up
ladies how are we doing yeah good to see
you i'd like to see you with a bone in
your mouth
happy yes good i thought it was lovely
the lamb was cooked to perfection i
love the lamb pink are you going to
finish that yes yeah i'll get upset if
you don't finish you know that
how many glasses of wine have you had
quite a lot fantastic yes
good to see you i was vegetarian until
two weeks ago
and i'm converted 110 now
i did think it was a bit pink but it's
the taste is just
fantastic absolutely fantastic laughing
and singing hello
oh no you devoured it you finished it
you know what i loved it
i've never had lamb rare before i've
always been a bit scared of the blood
but i love this it's nice not too much
blood oozing out no
and this time of year autumn has to be
the perfect time
um you said you don't cook at home you
must sort of
cook something um
i do do um toast and i do um
scrambled eggs in a microwave you put it
in a little bit of butter and a bit of
sea salt in because it makes me feel
like a chef
you cook scrambled egg yeah in a
microwave yeah
i don't have um saucepans or frying pans
i don't i don't want
one and i've got paper plates because i
can just chuck it in a bin i don't have
to wash it beautiful kitchen
nothing in no place nothing microwave to
cook scrambled again
you've got any knives in the kitchen a
couple of normal ones here
i'm gonna borrow you just for two
minutes i'm gonna show you something
absolutely crucial in the kitchen no no
no no
no no no no no don't worry about that
now just for two minutes now
um the most important thing about being
in the kitchen yeah okay
is um learning okay to sharpen
a knife goosebumps no goosebumps where
yeah
they're absolutely fine um right
okay what's that called uh
oh [ __ ] that's a steal so
we hold the steel there left hand and
you sharpen a knife
that way you can cut your vegetables
nice and thin you can cut your meat nice
and thin you can slice your fish right
left hand or right-handed
i'm right-handed yeah okay so that's my
left hand hold that in that hand
bear right just nice and slowly bend the
wrist
and show some flexibility on the wrist
there you go nice and slow kevin don't
cut yourself there you go
i never thought i'd be doing anything
like this with you
just like nine and a half weeks there
you go now bend that wrist it's too
stiff the wrist so you're left
underneath the right hand
i'm scared that's what's on your wrist
there's no flexibility in that wrist
there
now you no no no grace it nice nice big
long strokes
nice big long strokes of the knife and
there you go close your eyes yeah there
you go there we go
close my eyes yeah no because you just
listen to the noise
hear the noise yes there we go
yeah bit of rhythm look there you go
that nice there you go
okay so now you know how to sharpen the
knife is there anything else you want me
to do
for now no yay
[Laughter]
oh i thought oh god he's going to get me
to cut carrots really quickly with this
knife i can just feel it
he said that my wrist was too stiff you
probably wouldn't relax
i said i was scared that he was sort of
a bit of an innuendo with it and i
thought i'm not happy about that i love
that that'll do me no good whatsoever
your concentration face oh i know but so
close your eyes i thought
oh god what's he going to do to me i've
got a knife in my hand
that's a brave man to ask me to have a
knife and sharpen it with my eyes closed
yeah that's the brave man gordon ramsay
you're a brave man
goodness gracious i'm shaking
[Applause]
how's it going um how's absolutely
fantastic
really really good a very manly dish and
i noticed that you've got almost
exclusively women in the restaurant
tonight is this uh you trying to set me
up with somebody or what's up
i'm launching a campaign to get women
back in the kitchen oh you dog do you
think they want to go there no you know
what i'm fed
the customers coming into the kitchen 90
of them now they're all cooking at home
they're male 1 i'm amazed though you
commissioned that you actually went to
the links of commissioning a
survey to prove your your point and this
proved apparently that three-quarters of
women who can't cook
uh it's not that they cut they can't
cook and they don't care they can't go
they regret it i'm personally going on a
mission now
to invite every woman in the country
okay to get me in their kitchen
i'm gonna offer my services to the women
of britain starting tonight
excuse me sir our survey showed that
more men than women find cooking a
pleasure
while more women believe is a chore i've
been out and about across the country
and i've been shocked by what i've found
had a little brand new pan never been
used
for it the place is more set out like a
cocktail bar as opposed to a kitchen
over the next nine weeks i'm gonna be
helping women across the country to get
back in their kitchens why can't you
cook
i am a bit clumsy i know how to do it i
know he's supposed to do that
i poisoned my best friend oh dear
from steak and chips to sunday roast
they'll discover the pleasure of cooking
for their friends their families
and themselves smells fantastic
it does it never smells like this and in
return i want to promise that each woman
will say goodbye for good
to meals of chardonnay and crisps how
many tins of baked beans have you got
and hello to fantastic home-cooked food
i've never had
that many people sat around my table
what about a round of applause mummy
tell the neighbors the kitchen's been
used
the kitchen's been used right
while gordon reckons there must be
millions of women in britain who can't
cook and so he plans between now and
christmas to get as many of them as he
can back in the kitchen
so he's asked me to tell you that if
you're a woman and you can't cook and
you think he could help
get in touch with us via the website
better still if you're a man and you've
got a daughter
or a wife or a sister who can't cook let
us know and we'll see if we can't do you
a favor
and i tell you what if you can cook get
in touch with us anyway
especially if you're single put my name
on it maybe enclose a photographer the
people
now the people yeah yeah yeah yeah
hello enjoy lamb i love my lamb enjoy
the follow-up
fabulous when was last time you cooked
in the kitchen um oh
at the weekend another weekend yeah when
was last time we cooked in the kitchen
a month ago a month ago cj yeah
my campaign to get women further back
further back than that to get women back
in the kitchen and the campaign was
launched because
over the last four or five years 90 of
the people coming into my kitchen
yeah and fascinated about the cooking
i'm not the women best out of the table
having
wine and coffee because the men have got
time to come and see
you know you can spend 24 hours
marinating a gherkin
but women have got other things the kids
we've got the housework you didn't do
the housework
men have fallen in love with the
kitchens women have fallen out of love
with their kitchens well these two are
too young
but us two right we were the generation
argument now you know that
we were the generation we were told we
would be having it all
yeah we're not having it all we're doing
it all right and we haven't got
time to go in the kitchen and ponce
about
marinading something for 24 hours the
only reason you
can do that is because you've got a
lovely wife
who's at home with your guantanamo bay
turkeys
in the garden kanji and you're into
yourself when was the last time you
cooked
i haven't cooked for ages i haven't got
time i'm doing
homework i'm doing houses school runs
i'm doing work
yes okay i'm doing all the things that
my husband
doesn't have time my grandmother cooked
because she loved
cooking she did all the things that you
did without watching and without the
hoover yeah
anything else everything just said but
jay's saying now today's modern woman
doesn't have to cook because they're
busy
rubbish the art and the pride of being a
great cook
is making that time don't go shopping
but it's not cooked yeah it's not
spending three or four hours in the
kitchen it's just
cooking less time on the nails let's
start with the hair more time in the
kitchen jane
the nails can we look at the nails less
time on the nails
less time in the hair more time in the
kitchen jane rubbish busy busy see ya
dear oh dear
next on the menu it's pudding time al
murray takes me on with his recipe for
bread and butter pudding
sounds disgusting it's not disgusting
jars coring goes in search of the truth
about the drunkard's favorite
the donna kebab the donna kabab turns
out to be a gourmet production
[Applause]
welcome back to the f word now it's the
dessert time and that means bread and
butter pudding and the reason
why it is a bread butter pudding because
al murray challenged me to make one
better than him
each week on the f word i guess we'll
attempt to beat me by making their
favorite dessert
we'll each use our own recipe for the
same pudding and a panel of blind
tasters will choose their favorite
the winning dessert will be served to
the restaurant diners
bring it on kojak you haven't got a hope
right uh mr murray
you really think you can cook better
than me oh yeah gordon you're having a
laugh on you no
no no this is you know dead simple this
the whole the whole murray
food philosophy simple keep it simple
stupid okay so it's a thick cut loaf
curry yeah bit of milk yeah yeah it
sounds
disgusting is that it it's not
disgusting so how many eggs you put in
there
three you tight bastard
in my bread and butter pudding i'm gonna
use three whole eggs and three egg yolks
so get really nice rich
delicious custard can you stop watching
me because i think you're trying to
steal my recipe
would you like to be a proper chef one
day oh god no
no what would put you off the hours you
mate
[Laughter]
what do you mean me well you know
clearly plays havoc with a person being
a chef i mean i've hung out with sarge a
lot and he's not normal
so what have you done first tell me well
i've done the bread i've buttered the
pan you have to butter the pan children
yeah butter the powder it won't come off
the pan when you're washing it out what
are you flavoring your custard with
well sugar and lemon no alcohol no
alcohol no
are you putting alcohol in yours you
know it's sort of autumn so i'm gonna
put a little bit of bailey's
cream in there that's classy you know
what ladies like when they love baileys
and ice
it's a fruit-based drink for the lady
yeah
you know and you know what it just makes
that a little bit moreish yeah
yeah yeah i believe you you see my
baguettes are 24 hours old
are they yes that's what i'd heard so
because the drier they are
yeah the more custard they're the more
custard they absorb yeah like you've got
big fat stodgy bread
it's not gonna absorb any custard it's
gonna like eating dry bread ow
you can't do that to our customers
they're your customers i'm not here next
week so where you put the bottom of your
dish butter
and then the bread and then the bread on
top buttered bread on top of the butter
i'm putting a little bit of surprise at
the bottom of mine oh that's exciting
let's have a look have a look at what
you're actually doing here
what's this dry cranberries oh delicious
traditionally if i've got cystitis
because it's exactly what i need
i know come on come on hey hey that's
unfairness
that's good for the urinary tract that
is is it yeah it is actually did you
soak these
uh yes they're quite juicy just in hot
water that's all just to sort of
rehydrate them a little bit all right
so anyway before i say rudely
interrupted
and get the custard right which i didn't
bother cooking
right there's no point it's to cook in
the oven anyway all right he's
complicating it again
and you pour the custard in on top you
put the raisins on i've got some raisins
left
you see this is how i cook in a
haphazard mana lane german i'd defy
anyone to argue with my bread and butter
pudding
okay whilst now is making this bread and
butter sandwich full of raisins what
we've got here
is um the most amazing sort of soaked
24-hour old baguette
and it's done with a sort of bailey's
custard in between the layers
we've got sultanas golden raisins a
little bit of apricot jam
and then we're going to cover the top of
that with sugar so it caramelizes as it
cooks in the oven
and that's going to be 10 times better
than old chefs over there
that tastes like stale bread that's been
dipped in ale
and left outside for three weeks and
even the cat won't eat it
okay ready for the oven yeah absolutely
yeah here it comes
now just before it goes in there yeah
yeah yeah just just have a look
yeah and even before they're cooked yeah
yeah you know exactly which one's going
to come out best with a blind taster
that one
oh come on now the normal one you know
it's not down to the appearance is it
no it's the taste what matters is the
taste yeah taste taste taste
okay you want to say a little prayer
before no no no
no i'm a believer you're a believer
okay good luck my man thank you it looks
dry it looks dry
[Applause]
god dear blimey what a nerve on that al
murray i'll say
it's only better putting a nut you would
like that would you i wouldn't mind no
because it's not posh food is it
i don't only push food you do i don't
know if i'm drunk i'll eat anything
but when you're drunk you don't you wake
up in the morning you don't know what
you eat you don't really care
substance yeah but it's the same way you
you wake up in the morning next to
edwina curry and the reckoning of the
donna oh
which is worse the kebab yeah get a
gentleman
i'm a restaurant critic i eat only in
the finest restaurants i know what food
i'm eating i know where it's farmed i
know how it gets to my plate i don't
accept anything less
unless i'm drunk and there's licensing
laws change people are going to be drunk
all night
there's going to be nothing else open
and they'll make the same kind of
decision as me more and more
which is the terrible one of eating a
donut kebab
there you go and so we have a first in
the annals of food history adonai kebab
purchased stone cold sober i've got to
say i didn't know that it looked like
that
in fact i didn't know that it smelled
like that i think before i eat another
one of these
i'm gonna have to find out exactly what
goes into it i've got to find out
at the very least if it's even meat
[Music]
now of course some kebab shops make
their own kebabs but most get them from
a factory like this one in burton on
trent the idea of kebab and factory in
the same sentence seems a bit wrong i
don't eat food from factories very often
i have no idea what kind of terrible
things go on in there the kind of myths
and rooms i've heard make me feel sick
but i am going to go and have a look
700 million donors are sold in the uk
each year
and this factory alone produces 50
tonnes of kebab meat every week
but meat can mean all sorts of horrible
things and i'm hoping dominic jolovy the
quality assurance manager here can tell
me exactly what we're all eating
my word look at that look at that it's
it's uh it's real meat it's like a
butcher's shop i had no idea that
anything even resembling part of an
animal went into a kebab
as you can see here they're trimming up
all lamb breasts
right and the lamb breast is not being
used by supermarkets or restaurants
because it's very small because there's
not a high demand for it
as you can see a bit fatty bit fatty
very finicky to get you know nice chunks
of meat out of and the fact that this
stuff would normally just get thrown
away
ends up in a dynabab that's a good thing
and is that the end of the story what
else is there other carcasses there is
other trim as well i'll show you we also
use land fronts and shoulders
what happens is with these the
supermarkets sell the lamb cutlets
and the legs these lovely kind of jump
stops loins in there isn't it or these
are what you call a neck end
god there's a neck fillets though you
can eat them nicely well what we do with
these we take these
out and we sell these as shish i am
getting closer to eating a dona kebab
sober i think mm-hmm
what's this is very very good quality
products
so dominic what have we got here this is
slightly different these are
frozen fellows what's that this is beef
actually this is beef
well i said because some of our
customers we do do a lamb and beef
products right
and would you would a customer on in the
street know whether it's no they
probably wouldn't do
somebody who knows their kebabs would do
yeah because with wounded is that
someone like
me who's very finicky about the kind of
meat that i lamb
it's very limited to how intensively you
can farm it everyone's you know
reasonably safe with that beef one you
know
the beef market is slightly different
post bsc and everything and people are
a bit more worried about eating beef
it's odd that they would eat it without
knowing
well they would have to know because on
a kebab shop they should declare it if
it says donal kebab
it's a lamb right if it says kebab then
it may be lamb and beef ah
that's a crucial distinction to know
it's got to say don if it doesn't say
donna it could be anything this is where
all these spices and herbs are blended
oh get away helps the spices in a donuka
bab
we have salt garlic oregano uh coriander
that's so easy that's incredible isn't
it that sounds like gordon ramsay
characters that's the pottery thing i've
ever heard the donna kebab turns out to
be a gourmet production that's
thank you that's that's fascinating
this is where we make all the handmade
donnas and where the ones that come
pumped out in the machine
are finished off you're the dawn of the
donna's the king of the kebabs yeah the
shake of sheesh
how long does it take to make one of
these these whoppers five minutes five
minutes
you're a real artist then i mean i don't
think gordon ramsay could do a thing
like this
it's lovely stuff do you ever do you
ever sort of nick a bit and eat it as
you
no i don't know you're not hungry you've
had breakfast
you can eat
yeah i don't think it would fly out of
the shop too
with the skin first no no more meat
smooth small that size yeah you have to
measure it like i imagine in my mind
that's exactly the right side so i need
me no really you think my balls are
getting a little bit too big
one is a bit it doesn't matter one small
one before that does happen on we go
is that finished or do i put another one
on
look at that look at that we have to put
this one a museum
but you certainly wouldn't want to put
in your mouth
[Music]
so here we are then the first donna
kebab ever built by a restaurant critic
as i suspected it's fantastic and have
you seen what goes into it
i have to say i wouldn't probably serve
this kind of meat at my own table but
you know what
at least it's meat i tell you what else
it's not just kebabs that gels corians
eats when he's drunk you know that
last time he came to my restaurant we
had to tell him the next day what he had
for dinner we're joking he got so
pissed he phoned up the next day to sort
of be told what he had the night before
that's fantastic outrageous yeah
absolutely bloody food critics
it's the moment of truth the bread and
butter puddings
does yours look dry
look at that first beautiful
huh mine's not finished yet al oh of
course it isn't no
no but there's it's a little glaze you
know that
yeah apricot jam let down with some
water is that it
that's beautiful that is perfect god
dear oh dear
are you going to dust yours with icing
sugar no no no i can leave mine alone
serious you can't play with all that can
be possibly done with the
bread and butter pudding genre here
gordon
[Laughter]
okay john baptist yes take the egg
sandwich upstairs
and take my bread and butter pudding
alongside it please yes yeah and make
sure you've got some sick bags for the
sandwich next on the menu
which is the winner my wonderful bread
butter pudding or owl's bread sandwich
time for the result and the winner is
and i join marty mccutchen for coffee i
don't do journalists
you don't do jokes you do shows
welcome back now give me a very crucial
time because it's now the time to find
out
which dessert is the winner is it my
delicious sumptuous bread of pudding
or is it that sort of sliced white bread
egg sandwich of alma
is pretty obvious isn't it
the moment of truth it's important that
the pudding judges know what they're
talking about
so i tested the palettes of our diners
as they arrived
the ones who could recognize different
flavors will go on to choose which
dessert is best
they're blindfolded so they're only
assessing the food by taste
a lucky break for al if his was judged
by looks he'd be disqualified straight
away
for you to identify these combinations
first combination ready
i don't i don't know what that is at all
what's the fruit first you should know
where
right
beef beef good jam is it a fish
what's that taste something fruity
anyway rice pork
roast pork with apple with apple well
done
so that is what that's um
it's really chewy and bouncy like um
like a slug or something
off the spoon had that with my shoe shoe
last night
so that is what ro well done
now open white hmm
lovely mmm okay here we go
i can taste strawberries i'm not not
strawberries tomatoes
oh my god you said that hmm some kind of
grass rash i don't know
chewing and taste and i don't really
like it or
oh it's a bit peppermint would you like
to smoke it
does it work what does it spin off
come on dorothy definitely seafood
seafood
um salmon and
hmm take it all in good go
what's that taste of mmm mozzarella
good well done tomato tomato what's the
green leaf
basil well done well done well done
[Music]
the ones who got most foods right became
our pudding judges let's see what they
think
[Music]
that's this number one thank you
fruity soft you don't like it no
this is dish number two that's much
nicer yeah that is there is a real
difference
you can actually smell it the other one
was a bit too soggy
the moment of truth has finally arrived
[Applause]
there is one winner of course is one
winner and the winner is
[Laughter]
[Applause]
are you sure they find you're too heavy
actually they found mine too heavy yes
indeed
that can't be true i'm
you know when you go outside this door
you turn left by the traffic lights
and it's called a job center there yeah
now i can't believe that al's
monstrosity is going to be served in my
restaurant
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here we are giles oh my word
good god what's that when am i getting
pudding it's bread and butter pudding
you didn't eat it no it was it was very
sweet and and
it was you know it's what you want after
something savory but it was a bit gloopy
yeah and it wasn't very warm and i and i
and i don't like currants anyway
and i got more currants than anyone or
whatever they are you're quite a fuss
pot when it comes to food
i'd kind of like to avoid dairy if
possible
and i like to avoid um bread
bread wine just because it makes me
bloat and i don't feel good in my skinny
jeans
i'm still fascinated um finally just
just
almost in my own mind understand why you
weren't taught how to cook
well my mum did attempt it um a couple
of times
and after four hours of peeling a potato
and then ending up with about that much
because that's what was left he'll get
away
from that yeah and she just went off for
god's sake and chucked it in the rubbish
and that was that
and um i think that some people are just
naturally gifted at it and i'm not i'm
not good at it if there's one perfect
thing you'd love to learn how to cook
what would it be
a roast dinner a roast dinner yeah i'd
love to be able to cook a roast dinner
that's one thing that
i always love to eat lamb beef um
probably
beef beef and i want to do really lovely
yorkshire puddings but
there you go rice potatoes oh yeah yeah
oh yeah
i will come around and show you how to
cook the perfect sunday lunch okay
really really absolutely definitely but
where do i get my some spins and frying
pan from first
you've got nothing of that in the
kitchen i've got my tray in the oven
still unused with the instructions in it
that's how i've never used the oven
i don't even know how to switch another
one i will bring all that with me okay
roasting trade pots pans sauces you name
it i'll bring
china plates as long as you promise me
one thing after i've gone
yeah you continue doing it okay
all right minimum yeah once a month no
minimum once a month
once a month okay once a month we're
cooking yeah
should we shake them up kiss on it okay
[Applause]
so what do you think charles it's our
wallpaper bait
no it's not nice too i've never put up
any wallpapers i wouldn't know you
wouldn't know you've never worked
down a day's and is this that just in
your life is this grilled or is this
just allowed to go stale
no it's you see my grandmother made this
she was an
austrian lady and when did you make it
1943.
now you're beginning to upset me on the
verge of insulting my friend what always
happened with restaurant criticism it
turns out that no because your
grandmother was a great woman yes she
certainly was
and she endured the blitz to give you
this recipe
in your time you've kissed the most
amazing guys yeah hugh grant and ross
came for no no
and there's one sort of knobby no mates
around here somewhere
um would you ever kiss girls corrin i
don't know who that is
um he's a food critic right to
oh he's over there the one with this
sort of hairy face if you saw him
he's sort of helping co present he's a
journalist and he's single i don't do
journalists
you don't do journals do you do checks
[Laughter]
i've never seen a sort of girl serve you
know tea the way you did it down in the
street
oh my god beautiful beautiful barmaid
independence
thank you just before we go we've had
the stuff we've had the lamb we've had
the pudding
i want you to help john baptist just on
a few tables serve some coffee
like a proper way to say i want to see
what you like naturally
if you can actually go around the tables
with that
watching you yeah instead of teasing
coffee he's going to give me an insight
to what it's like
going around your kitchen coming around
i'll give it april i i've got high heels
on i'll just about
never mind just a couple of times